hello welcome to this video Peregrine 64
let's do something else might still end
up being an Enzo no it isn't i had some
kind of weird Kings Indian where it
tries to make some sense out of that III
move interesting yeah so of course I can
just I can't just move the noise and I
think I will I was just thinking maybe I
can do something something special but
let's not do something special let's
just play normal stuff be quick for once
yeah they have to prepare some kind of
f5 here anyway here we go so maybe like
age 65 the Kings Indian after all okay
quite sure what he's doing is he
preparing some kind of tactic on the a
2g eight diagonal I don't see that
working
Queen a five or something you're happy
six even know I'm just going to play
f/4g for h5 and kind of throw the
kitchen sink I mean this Bishop won't be
too is looking kind of kind of wrong
well and it's not so bad i believe just
f 4g 4 and so on where is he going I'm
going for checkmate I know the target
may be Queen be a drug see one something
like that maybe yeah maybe so let's try
to play Queen B atl yeah that's
definitely a definitely on hmm so what
to do 57 legals Queen B seven so i
probably have to move the bishop somehow
but on Queen B 8 I can't go back to e7
this is not it's not clear that is so
terrible but I really don't see much
wrong with that I mean okay it loses be
seven but anyway
point to the two probably so now Quinn
g5 I guess I'm have to get some stuff
near the kingside objectively speaking
this is probably very good for white but
still has to be as we play it by cheek
Knight f6 I guess or does he already
take material then i also have that 22
resource I wonder f3 maybe let's do this
let's do this I was thinking Queen d2
but in fact my bishop is hanging so that
was a rather stupid idea so I'm going to
recapture know yeah probably an engine
would find some kind of win here for
white but sets tits definitely not easy
no really Queen d2 isn't this dangerous
for your king squiddy one made huh what
does then bishop f3 or what not taking
be to know i don't think that this was
right i am i missing stuff
yeah yeah that that wasn't the way to do
it for white now that I was very very
use planar probably buy me some some
there was certainly some ways for y to
win the game yeah even that still not
loopy one yeah I was just thinking I
this might be might be still still still
there but can I go this then no here
maybe 43 now I have III right where
Queen takes is made maybe could have
gone look everyone check checkmate yeah
that's a typical Kings Indian yeah kind
of swindling attack okay maybe I can
really do 97 yeah I saw that movie have
I mentioned that during the country that
the comp actually gives 97 just keeping
things together I thought that it's
playable but hmm I want it to be more
aggressive here and maybe this is just
not working so this this is already a
mistake according to the comp aha but
not because of what I played not because
of this this losers but this is good at
night and forth oh that's a nice tactic
here double-checking f24 you can check
and this is very dangerous for watchin
engines has equal but it's dangerous and
here a computer just says you three and
it's over yeah that's not such an easy
move to make for a human because you
kind of think Queen 283 and you're mated
but no I don't quite get it the engine
gives this because of this move okay now
that's difficult can can you do do this
now then i have e four so there's
probably only this inhuman move Queen d7
that that ends that because of this
thread okay wyd wins yeah funny yeah so
okay took but that also wins
interestingly enough 27 again does win
but this losers yeah it's difficult it's
difficult to play this is not clear at
all efore we should be eight now III dis
win yeah who gave one though he has to
play Jack I think I can take cash check
but how do I win now i can check here
okay i can take this and then continue
the attack okay probably yeah that's
wind n minus five so some kind of
material win probably winning the ruckus
oh yeah this is typical king's indian
type of counterplay where every mistake
can cost wide the game while black is
often like material down but in a
practical game especially a blitz game
it's super difficult to handle okay well
thanks for watching